welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman but as i
mentioned the beginning of the show
david will in fact be back on monday
with fresh content for you
but for now
let's get right back to it of course
one of the biggest things this week was
the turning point usa conference
and as we all know one of the featured
speakers was kyle riddenhaus
and when rittenhouse emerged onto that
stage
it was basically like wwe
right
he had his own theme song that they
created for him so
if you haven't already seen the video
brace yourselves
because here is kyle ridden house's
entrance
into that turning point usa conference
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the clouds
[Music]
[Applause]
like a clown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the crowd loved him you heard channing
kyle kyle
but there was one person
that was not happy about this there was
one conservative
who understood that maybe this isn't the
best guy
to be hoisting upon our collective
shoulders
and believe it or not folks that person
happens to be fox contributor tomi
larin
on an episode of outnumbered
this week
larryn
actually i can't say she laid into
conservatives for
idolizing kyle rittenhouse but she did
question
why they're treating him like a rock
star here's what she had to say
i do think that as conservatives we need
to be a little careful when it comes to
this
i believe we can put up kyle ridden
house as someone who was innocent and
was bullied by mistreated by the media
but i think we should step back a little
maybe not treat him like he's a rock
star or a celebrity
i don't think that's necessarily a good
look for the conservative movement
he did what he had to do he was
defending himself let's talk about
self-defense let's talk about the riots
let's talk about how everything went
horribly horribly wrong that day
but i think we should take a step back
and not make the man bon jovi
but that's just my take she says
of course that's how that's just my
opinion you know
don't don't kill the messenger
here's the thing
she's right
that's a weird thing to say
but tomi lahren is right
and she's right
for several reasons
the first is
what's he done
well let's be honest we all know what
happened
two people are dead kyle ridden house
was acquitted
now we could argue all day long whether
or not you think it was self-defense
whether you think he should be here but
those arguments no longer really matter
okay kyle rittenhouse
faced the jury
he had his defense
we had the prosecutors
defense prevailed kyle rittenhouse was
acquitted
that's the end of that so we're not even
going to get into that
but two people are dead and we know that
he killed him the court says it's in
self-defense so we have to accept that
and now he's a hero
like now they're lifting him up now they
gave him a speaking gig
now i'll be perfectly honest with you i
don't know what he said i didn't listen
to it i have no interest in listening to
it i don't care what he has to say
although we do know
that he did say in an interview after
the acquittal that you know people
shouldn't be praising him for this
i guess he's i guess he's okay with it
now
but either way laryn's point i think i
don't want to put words in her mouth but
i think what she's trying to get at is
why
what's the longevity
of kyle rittenhouse
what is he actually doing to further the
conservative cause
so the answer to that question would
obviously be
nothing
not a thing
and of course turning point is supposed
to be about these conservatives who are
out there making a difference pushing
their horrible conservative policies on
us spitting out giving us new
conservative talking points
but that's not what kyle rittenhouse is
he's not a political operative
i mean he's a
kid he's a kid that's now gotten swept
up into all of this
and honestly
i don't think he understands it either i
don't think he knows where he's going
with this
does he have a future in the
conservative movement
does kyle rittenhouse have a shelf life
and that's the big point that tomi
lahren herself is attempting to make
think of it this way
i pointed this out actually on fair and
balanced as well
um the mccloskeys right the st louis gun
couple we all remember them right
what what are they doing now
they were conservative heroes
heck they had a speaking spot
at the gop convention last year where
are they now are they still these
conservative rising stars i know i know
the the guy was gonna run for senate and
i don't think that went very well for
him
i don't even know if that's still
happening
because nobody cares about the
mccloskeys anymore
and the same thing will eventually
happen to kyle rittenhouse
you know maybe
you know the gun rights organizations
will try to use him as a poster child
maybe he'll do that maybe he won't
that's all pure speculation at this
point to be honest we don't know what he
will or will not do with this newfound
fame
but one thing we can pretty much all
come to the same conclusion on
is that based on others who've been in
this situation before the fame doesn't
last
the spotlights fade
they disappear and people will forget
except the families affected
who this individual is and they won't
care anymore
and i would like to think that that's
what tomi lahren was getting at
but i also think
there could be a degree of jealousy
there right
and let's face it a couple years ago
tomi lahren was the it girl right
she was the one everybody was clamoring
for she was the one making the headlines
she was the one out there
helping
craft the direction of the republican
party
a lot of people forgot she existed
so maybe
maybe and this is you know to to pull a
laryn that's just my opinion maybe
she's a little jealous of having to
share the spotlight
maybe she's a little jealous that the
spotlight's not on her anymore
you know people have moved on
and what's funny about that is i
actually said that many years ago when
she first burst onto the scene
because i have been in this business for
going on 18 years
we have seen them come and go
we have seen the fly-by-nighters they
make a big pop they make a big splash
they hang around for a bit sell a couple
of books and then they disappear
they fade off into obscurity because the
republican movement you know this
conservative media thing it's always
trying to find the next hero trying to
find the next big thing trying to find
the next pretty face in many instances
and tomi's star is fading
relegated to a
weird show on fox having to appear on a
midday show to
tell people that it's a little
cringe-worthy what the republicans are
doing with kyle rittenhouse
yeah
next stop is hollywood squares maybe
dancing with the stars
and people will have forgotten all about
tomi lahren at that point
and
that's i think what really scares her
the most
yes conservatives should not be hoisting
kyle rittenhouse upon their shoulders
but tomi lahren speaks from experience
she knows what it's like
as she knows how much it hurts
when you come crashing down to reality
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video